i
[Música]
ah
no existen cifras oficiales sobre la
deuda externa de venezuela sin embargo
analistas del país señalan que asciende
a 136 mil millones de dólares en este
monto están incluido el endeudamiento
bilateral contraído con china y rúsia y
también en lo que se le debe a los
organismos multilaterales pero no los
gastos de laudos ni procesos legales por
expropiaciones el monto de deuda
equivale al doscientos ochenta y nueve
por ciento del producto interno bruto
del país venezuela está en suspensión de
pagos desde el año 2017 y el default
está en el orden de los 23.000 millones
de dólares según los expertos el
gobierno de nicolás maduro ha dicho que
las sanciones de eeuu contra sus
funcionarios empresas públicas y
sistemas financieros le han impedido
cumplir con las obligaciones la ministra
de finanzas del cid rodríguez señaló el
pasado mes de septiembre que actualmente
está en un proceso de negociación de
deuda y le ofrece a los tenedores de
títulos emitidos por la república una
oferta condicional que tendrán que
aceptar o rechazar antes de la
medianoche del 13 de octubre
[Música]
hasta abril de este año bolivia tenía
una deuda externa cifrada en 11.600
millones de dólares lo que equivale al
27 por ciento del producto interior
bruto sin embargo el país además tiene
una deuda interna que llega a los 8 mil
millones de dólares de los cuales el 45
por ciento es deuda privada la pandemia
ha empeorado la situación de
endeudamiento del país
de hecho el gobierno de jeanine áñez ha
anunciado que está tramitando un crédito
del banco mundial y el banco
interamericano de desarrollo de 7 mil
millones de dólares para que los
próximos años se pueda reactivar la
economía del país los partidos políticos
que se encuentran en campaña electoral
también han abierto el debate sobre si
se debe o no seguir pagando la deuda en
el marco de esta crisis y de hecho el
candidato del movimiento al socialismo
luís arce que es el mejor posicionado en
las encuestas ha propuesto que se deje
de pagar la deuda durante dos años
[Música]
con una deuda externa que asciende a los
12 mil millones de dólares equivalente
al 31 por ciento del producto interno
bruto de paraguay el gobierno de este
país enfrenta un histórico endeudamiento
ya que al menos desde 1989 cuando se
restableció el periodo democrático no se
había observado un nivel de
endeudamiento tan alto el panorama
económico es preocupante ya que se
espera que para el final de este período
administrativo que culminará en
diciembre de 2020 la deuda externa
llegue al 35 por ciento del producto
interno bruto los principales acreedores
de la deuda paraguaya sobre el banco
mundial y el banco interamericano de
desarrollo los expertos en el área
económica incluidos entre ellos varios
ex ministros de hacienda de distintos
gobiernos han advertido con preocupación
que el ritmo de endeudamiento es
demasiado acelerado y debe ser frenado
ya que la capacidad de pago de paraguay
ha sido superada
[Música]